Oi bom dia pai está seguir a mulher do
Norte vai ser muito difícil sou o último
esta história dos eventos sem intervalos
tudo isto muito difícil além de tudo a
Joana já não atua ver mas ainda me
roubou o argumento da receita que o
vinho exatamente pegado no que é que são
as receitas ou do que podem ser as
receitas nas nossas escolas bem e esta
quais a pergunta de partidas na educação
existe ou não receitas
e eu diria que se calhar receitas não
existem mas como dizia a Joana existem
ingredientes existe um conjunto de
ingredientes que quando combinados com o
contexto certo e com e na Dose Certa se
calhar podem funcionar e surgiu o
caminho este desafio olhar e pensar no
que é que tem as escolas de sucesso de
conhecer muitas escolas em muitas
realidades E aí nos contextos e
percebemos que de fato a um conjunto de
critérios a um conjunto de dados que
fazem com que naquele momento e naquele
contest fato as escolas possam funcionar
escolas enquanto sistemas porque nós
sabemos enfim jogos Applebee's temos
pessoas absolutamente brilhantes todos
extraordinários e que acreditam
verdadeiramente na sua missão e nos seus
alunos mas muito mais difícil que isso é
transformar o sistema enfim ouvimos
também a ordem do dia rankings públicas
ou privadas nos transformar as escolas
transformar organizações o que ela está
em qualquer um que ela está
é o que o que ela está indo também de
desafiantes e com aquilo que são as
grandes questões bem o que elas têm de
alguma maneira são escolas que se
transformam que têm esta capacidade eu
já falamos muito eventos o look e também
tem esta capacidade de assumir que podem
errar às vezes esse é um erro e hoje
falamos muito Diogo que a seguir as
coisas que a escola mais fortes do erro
esta ideia de que podemos arriscar
podemos mudar podemos mudar tudo na
verdade hoje quase podemos mudar tudo
disciplinas horários calendários e a
forma essencialmente isto a forma de
trabalhar e isto hoje também é
importante pensar que bate calhar pedido
a outra dimensão e que elas têm e que
esta se calhar nos cantinhos não é bem
mas que conta as escolas as Tais escolas
especiais que todos nós conhecemos e
reconhecemos muitas são escolas na e
para a comunidade questão da comunidade
que se envolvem que que de fato também e
já os aqui 20 tem projetos mas tem
projetos estruturantes a comunidade faz
parte e aquelas escolas estão por que
estão naquela comunidade e se tivessem
outra coisa no outro convidar seria
outra escola qualquer esta outra
dimensão e outro espaço o que que nestas
escolas faz a diferença e que inventam o
espaço e reinventam o tempo o espaço
onde as atividades ocorrem o tempo em
que ocorrem e como ocorre e aquilo Como
faz toda a diferença e aqui já ouvimos a
Joana também disse aquela ideia de que
mudar o centro os alunos e Inês também
de aluna apresentava aqui no palco
asteroide que o Paulo
a aprendizagem Edilson e os que aprendem
e que a centralidade tem e temos que
assumir que deve ser dos alunos antes e
depois essa ideia da sala de aula que é
que tudo acontece porque na verdade e aí
cada um de nós tem este tal poder e não
sei se é só na sala de aula em todos os
contatos Mas esta esta esta dimensão de
Inovar e de mudar a sala de aula então
quais são e aqui sim os pais e São 17 17
anos enfim desde o mais macron e tentar
chegar ao mais magro ou mais micro micro
e terminar dentro da sala de aula mas
que quando combinados me parece e se
olharmos isso conseguimos que fazem e
que são os tais ingredientes importantes
o primeiro deles
bom e que acho que isso não falamos aqui
de hoje eu hoje mas que é muito
importante as lideranças escolares as
lembranças escolares que fazem a
diferença ocupando escolas é uma mera
organização com muitas vezes com 300 400
profissionais com milhares de pessoas
que diariamente habitam aquela
organização a qualidade das lideranças a
capacidade de envolver a capacidade de
escutar e capacidade se calhar mais
importantes dos líderes de envolver em e
desenvolverem para a mudança uma mudança
que implique todos e esta é um ponto que
me parece importante e tchau enfim até
muitos dados que nos dizem que se calhar
a qualidade das lideranças tem
implicações diretas no sucesso educativo
e que se calhar também é e um ponto
podemos pensar o
e depois outro espaço inovação em
impressão pedagógica Nós não combinamos
e palavra mais dita hoje é o erro e
ainda são perigosas e quem Isto é nós
achamos que podíamos errar e se calhar a
nossa profissão em nossa área é aquela
em que temos sempre mais dificuldades ou
temos sempre ouvimos sem poluir com
qualquer coisa Sempre visitar e é que
tem que nós próprios nos damos menos
espaços a errar e vemos-nos -
oportunidade de experimentar e de falhar
e portanto hoje temos a este espaço os
podemos experimentar novas soluções e
por quê porque provavelmente
instrumentos de valente não acredito
mesmo que temos um instrumento
extraordinário que nos permite isto isto
é o perfil Isto é aquilo que nós temos
que trabalhar daqueles saio no final da
segurar obrigatórios não é
necessariamente com o ranking de fundos
Isto é contudo é verdadeiramente a tal
intersecualidade trabalhar algo como um
todo trabalhar num e pulo de facto no
centro do nosso processo
a intenção é este é de alguma forma
aquilo que temos que olhar diariamente
quando vemos nossos alunos entrarem
dentro da nossa sala de aula
é o terceiro informação e avaliação
informação toda ela rankings também há
coisas que não podemos olhar para eles
como de alguma maneira alguns aparecem
mas a coisas importantes e dados que às
vezes até difícil explicar uma coisa que
aparece todos os anos por exemplo e que
o próprio muito rock porque porque é que
os alunos o norte nas escolas no norte
do país tem normalmente sempre os
melhores resultados que as escolas do
sul do país é curioso nós estamos no sul
e aqui na é privado e público não é
nenhuma outra comparação é tão simples e
se calhar podemos aprender com eles
podemos mas há outras informações a
outros projetos que nós podemos olhar
para avaliação externa das escolas ou
pizza agora O pisa nas escolas que
alguns municípios estão aderir com
muitas escolas e informação compreender
e conhecer a nossa comunidade
compreender os desejos e as dificuldades
dos nossos professores ouvir os nossos
alunos decidir com informação se vestir
de acordo com quem são os nossos e
também parece que que é outro lado e ou
um importante ingrediente gastar as
escolas especiais informação e avaliação
é o quarto as escolas abertas ao mundo
as Tais escolas comprometidas com a
comunidade que participa O que houve em
que vão ao bairro traz o bairro a escola
e as escolas que são comunidades esta
ideia de que as escolas mais e que se
comprometem em escolas que de facto não
se separam do mundo as escolas estão
existem naquele contexto Este é um
ingrediente também gostei e depois outro
também dia e já que falamos de
comunicação a ideia de comunicar uma só
voz e aqui para mim eu acho que trouxe
uma nova oportunidade trouxe um outro
cuidado de organizar estratégia da
escola de organizar até lógicas de visão
e lógicas de comunicação coisas tão
simples ainda manhã falar vamos aqui o
início hoje e se calhar um ano e pouco
atraz estão esse todas as pessoas têm um
e-mail institucional todos os alunos têm
o tem um e-mail e Sinal da Escola acho
que a escola ter uma agenda em que todos
os seus funcionários e colaboradores
sabem o que se passa nas unhas
e não conseguiram autor da biblioteca
nesta semana sabem que vai haver três ou
quatro alunos da Escola Como apresentar
um projeto e vou apresentar a escola
sentiu a ouvir e isto que se calhar não
diria que nos faz todo sentido isso não
acontece muitos sítios no dia a dia Isto
é importante Isto é como pura de escola
e a valorização da escola e esta
comunicação se calhar que nem pensar
para dentro da escola mas será tem esses
três níveis que eu acho que são
importantes quando falamos comunicação
comunicação com As equipas com os
coordenadores e essa ideia de que não
pode ser igual o que for para colocar na
escola a ouvir não pode ser escolas são
diferentes têm visões diferentes o
processo diferente e tem alunos
diferentes e cada uma e cada escola tem
que ser neste aspecto e repetível e só
se ela for pedir a ela que nós temos de
facto a trabalhar para aqueles alunos e
para aquela comunidade mas aqui também a
ideia de trabalhar as famílias e
comunicar com as famílias e de comunicar
positivamente com a família
o jogo e consumos essa ideia de
linguagem e códigos os conhecer e
perceber o que é que os interessa Quais
são os seus interesses e de conseguimos
chegar nos e de conseguimos sermos
relevantes para os nossos alunos o
também sabemos que se não formos a nossa
missão é mais dificultado aquela ideia
Joana disse a pouco de nos darmos aos
nossos alunos a outros Passos importante
e relevante
e depois este espaço comunidade cuidado
mais aberta essa ideia de que de facto
os próprios municípios estamos em Oeiras
Esta foto é do acidente que a políticas
municipais para a educação Ainda bem que
existem que as escolas devem ter
urgência efetivos próprios e que
educarmos os nossos as crianças os
nossos jovens em missão de todos não é E
esta ideia de comunidade que fica
estiver que também representam
camionistas ali os alunos da Vale do Rio
que é uma escola profissional de letras
e somos todos e esta visão de que o
futuro e de que de facto muitos
municípios até extravasam as suas
competências naquilo que a educação
porque porque acreditam que isto é
absolutamente importante que se calhar
muitas a solução muito caminho está aqui
e as escolas que aproveitam estou
aproveitando estrategicamente não
sabemos onde aquela loja que vamos lá
pedir a câmera um assunto qualquer sítio
no Autocarro que não temos um projeto
estruturante com os nossos alunos temos
uma visão integrada
o que o que é o nosso território e este
também aqui no espaço e um ponto clique
que me parece pode ser útil para este
para esta discussão
e depois os professores o pessoal
docente
um banho e aqui nós hoje se vemos aqui
estamos cá para bloquear por caminhos
extraordinários poderes extraordinários
exemplos
É mas aqui em grandes desafios nesta
questão do Sol sim desafios por exemplo
hoje as 15 anos são um por cento os
nossos alguns é que disse que é ser
professor nós temos professores sempre
uma profissão brutalmente tiver decida
temos muitos muita gente que não quer
ser professora e temos atende as
expectativas dos três e objetivos do
próprio do Bernardo essa ideia de que
ser professora Edifício esta ideia de
que isto temos porque o Reinventar e
temos que Reinventar os russos que
joelhos com todos mas essa ideia de
recentrar e de valorizar aquilo que a
função descendente Este é um enorme
desafio e não devemos esquecer porque
hoje estamos aqui em fins temos todos
extraordinariamente impressionados ainda
essa com aquilo que é o seu saúde esse
professor mas essa também não é
realidade toda e também acho que é
importante se calhar podemos central e
pensá-la desta desta forma depois outro
espaço essa ideia do pessoal não sei se
essa ideia que nós achamos que se possa
ensina na AL
e aqueles que ensinam e os que não
ensinam essa ideia da negação eu não sei
que o nome técnica o técnico educação
técnicos auxiliares este ideia da do não
sentido não importante muitas destas
pessoas com aquelas aqui nós deixamos os
nossos filhos a porta da escola de manhã
com nós vamos tem papel fundamental são
referências assistências do pré-escolar
e do 1º ciclo não distinguem quem é o
suficiente e não se distinguem
referências pessoas que têm gostam
pessoas cozido e quis ajudar e aqui
também há muitos projetos hoje bem de
valorizar Esta função essencial eles
conhecem verdadeiramente os nossos
filhos nossos alunos conhecem nos em
todos os contatos e não só dentro da
sala de aula e tanto também aqui esta
ideia de que a escola somos uma equipa
somos uma equipa pedagógica e este é o
ingrediente que hoje muitas escolas que
os municípios também têm e tela muitos
destes funcionários trabalho trabalhados
neste ideia tendo própria autoestima de
que são importantes e muitas vezes eles
não são
é só nós Nos olhamos com importância
eles são pais fiquem visíveis
E tu só tem os alunos
e os alunos é este passo que fazem parte
é esta coisa de ter o seu palco a Inês a
brilhantemente ainda aluna Este é o
nosso desafio é transformar isso essa
ideia de que o palco bolacha e dos
amigos essa ideia de que nós precisamos
de trazer os exames de os ouvir
precisamos desmotivar e esta atrair a
aprendizagem é que saco deles e este
caminho de que os alunos têm um papel
determinante é muito muito importante e
se calhar que o ponto mais polêmico não
saio dessa mas não sabemos tantas vezes
esta discussão que a família não ajuda
que a família é difícil que a família
assim essa ameaçado bem eu vou mesmo
voltar para trás para conseguir ler não
é família que ajuda a escola na formação
da Criança é o contrário E esta ideia
que se repete sempre e que nos tem que
mobilizar para a Contrariar de que por
exemplo a escolaridade da mãe
nós fizemos tecido cativo do filho Isto
é contradição de educação eu uso social
nós temos que ser capaz de Contrariar
isso temos que ser capazes de trabalhar
com aquelas crianças que o pai ajuda que
tem a família mas também tem que ser
capaz de trabalhar com aquelas crianças
que não tenho a família e com aquela os
pais para ajudar porque são essas que
precisam mais das nossas escolas e são
essas precisam mais de nós é difícil
claro que é difícil seus pais do se
tivéssemos estivermos alinhados é mais
fácil naturalmente mas temos que a
evitar esta esta é a vezes me desculpa
se eu for mas assumiu sempre tem sempre
todas e feliz e temos que encontrar as
melhores soluções possíveis para todos
para todos e para todos porque Subimos
todos algumas a nossa escola felizmente
é um desafio é é Um Desafio ótimo temos
uma escolaridade obrigatória 12 anos de
todos terem que ir à escola portugueses
Emigrantes falantes de português ou não
estão todos com dificuldades ou não
estão todos rapazes raparigas todas as
e essa ideia de incluir esta ideia que
muitas escolas conseguem transformar
como um ganho e não como uma dificuldade
que é a dificuldade o código cultural a
riqueza Cultural de cada um é uma
oportunidade de aprendizagem e não é um
entrave não é uma dificuldade e portanto
este Grande Desafio que importa também
trazer depois o espaço e criatividade a
Ivete disso tudo eu tenho pouco tempo já
tem sim a criatividade o erro de
estarmos o desafiar os E esta ideia do
projeto do projeto integral no projeto
que os porque no projeto com a
construção das soluções e depois com
outra dimensão que é o projeto que é
sumido tenho um Palco que termina com um
produto termina com a aprendizagem o
aprendizagem dos conhecimentos e com o
treino das competências porque às vezes
também esta coisa de que o espaço e a
criatividade e as competências o
conhecimento não aconteça sem
conhecimento as duas coisas andam juntas
eu tenho competências que aprendi
Ah e não alguma coisa sozinha nem nós
precisamos disso podemos muito
competências Porque nós não fazemos irá
conhecimentos é como se precisar amanhã
no mercado trabalho também este outro
espaço importante de tal criatividade e
tecnologia também você muito rápido já
que falamos muito tecnologia até que um
dia vai à escola telemóveis fora da sala
de aula dentro da sala de aula mas qual
é a vida tem que haver tecnologia na
escola como a vida e tá caindo nos
mesmos tem que usar a tecnologia na
escola como usam nas nas suas casas da
mesma forma uma vantagem a tecnologia
tem uma oportunidade de diversificar
estratégias porque ele se tiver só uma
mesa e o manual tenho duas outras
possibilidades se tiver até que hoje tem
muitas outras possibilidades o centro é
pedagogia naturalmente o centro a
relação com o professor naturalmente
tecnologia é uma ferramenta como
qualquer outra e tem espaço na escola
que deve ter E tantas outras devem ter
se elevem os aqui a motivação EA
tecnologia também pode ser um espaço ou
meio para a motivação os nossos alunos
são diferentes são hiperestimulados vez
que nascem olham para um livro e com
isso a fazer assim o livro eles acham
que aquilo é um tablet e tá legal esse é
o nova realidade e não vale a pena com
trabalharmos e achamos que temos que
ensinar que não posso tempo temos
encontrado encontrar estratégias para os
motivar para trabalhar com eles e para
que eles tenham vontade de aprender nós
não ensinarmos só se não tiverem vontade
de aprender e a motivação é Central as
escolas que trabalham isto que envolvem
os Miúdos têm muitas dinâmicas e
assembleias de alunos em que incentivam
que eles participem aquele símbolo o que
eles façam parte daquela comunidade e
que no fundo fazem isso incentivo
aqueles motivo é que eles queiram
aprender não é muito no fundo o jovem e
que querem saber quais são os seus
interesses
bom e vamos levar isto a diversidade de
práticas eu estou muito muito atrasado
não é para tu estás não posso não é E
esta ideia e aqui é um ganho que eu acho
que ganhamos com companhia Este último
este mundo não este que no último. Este
é que ideia do Trabalho em rede trabalho
colaborativo as escolas são espaços
habitados por muitos profissionais por
uns do centro muito profissionais e
perguntas equipas até multidisciplinares
mas depois tem um ato educativo muito
solitário qualidade que a minha sala de
aula os seus alunos O que eu faço lá
dentro e às vezes até ainda a ideia da
Porta Fechada aprende a minha trouxe nos
diz tudo de bom acho eu acho a educação
que é que os professores a conversarem
os professores a pensar em planos de
trabalho semanal para os alunos que são
João concelho turma pois os professores
aplicar recursos que faziam para
entregar aos alunos Isto é bom é muito
importante consigamos trazer Isto é
muito importante nos nossos 100 alunos
das nossas turmas ou mais às vezes
conseguimos partilhar as cinco lado
temos um aluno os nossos colegas
nós conseguimos perceber estratégias é
que funcionam com uns que não funcionam
com outros este espaço o digital a
partilha das atividades o pensar a turno
pensar o aluno pensar no trabalho com um
tudo e nos partir da minha gaveta do meu
português da minha Matemática é uma
oportunidade que tive que é importante
que não percamos é uma oportunidade
muito interessante e isto foi talvez das
coisas que ainda hoje Estão na escola
que aprende me amostrou por sumos É
verdade mas eu acho que se partilharmos
se abrirmos é mais fácil e se calhar faz
mais sentido para os nossos alunos
porque não tem besta essas diferentes
que não se interligam quando era nenhuma
Mas podem ter qualquer coisa integrado
nos faça sentido e para nós pode ser
também muito mais interesse em
o espaço bastão saudável que é que
termine aquilo que é mais importante é
ação é aprendizagem isto claro que todos
os outros fatores interessa o que os
outros fatores agindo por fazer
estiverem interligados esses Tais
ingredientes e um se calhar tenho
melhores condições para fazer acontecido
para a tal magia e coloca em todas as
escolas nós temos custos extraordinários
mas a ideia criarmos e isso é importante
que eu sei que esses agrupamentos de
escolas e escolas que fazem que
facilitam isto que dão melhor espaços e
oportunidades para que alunos e
professores visão a sala de aula e
construa o melhor a sua e o seu processo
de aprendizagem
a receita a Joana roubar uma ideia ou
roubar elas gostam combinamos aceita
final e quase que em tom de brincadeira
e que eu não consigo explicar sei ler
mas que de alguma maneira é extremamente
o erro as receitas que funcionam são
aquelas que implicam não temos medo do
erro não temos medo fazer diferente não
temos medo experimentar uma atividade
Que Nunca fizemos não termos medo de
fazer um projeto Que Nunca fizemos que
pode correr mal mas errar também é
aprender mas cortamos nos guiar os
adultos você Ramos as atividades
profissionais nós fazemos imensa coisa
que se calhar depois de fazer faremos
maneira diferente e temos que assumir
que o erro é importante e que faz parte
do próprio processo de alguma maneira
essa ideia de uma mão cheia de liderança
um quilo de vontade de mudar uma pitada
tecnologia Integradas comunidade uma
dose Generosa de comunicação comunicação
empática e conta um olho de excelentes
profissionais uma dose de inclusão o
Muita criatividade
o coração e por último esperar um a
gente tem tempo começar e terminar
sempre e sempre envolvendo e envolver os
nossos alunos naquilo que a sua
aprendizagem Muito obrigado
[Aplausos]